what's the story Ron Diane making you
sell this place not at all
recently I purchased a new cabin big
enough for the whole family I just can't
justify owning four cabins two cabins
the new cabin I bought has a great tire
swing for the girls access to a lake for
all the kids to play in plus it doesn't
have these razor-sharp perimeter defense
planks sticking out of the ground I
usually get five percent commission but
I'll do it for three friends and family
discount make it five I don't want you
getting any ideas about us being friends
respect Donna baby for the fireplace I'm
thinking fake antlers but what kind of
scars we want to hang out - fake antlers
Oh duh
no shade most staff that'll look legit
next to those antique visit France
posters Oh Ron you want to stay out so I
didn't do nothing while they make your
cabin look like garbage I'd like that
very much
we can watch the shadows get longer okay
these people won't leave one guy even
looked in the bathroom yeah
that means they like the place if you
just leave them alone I think we might
get some offers this evergreen scented
candle should help the people in the
mood to buy you could just open the door
and let the actual smell of the pines
and trees are sticky and they get bugs
in them this place is so random I don't
know it's kind of like in the middle of
nowhere I know that's like the hilarious
part it's like a joke how long it takes
to get here it's like a meta common I
heard that Dave Eggers wrote a short
story about this tape cassette that he
found under that tree over there I'm
good what are you doing
trying to get these annoying thumb does
it pay more money for your cabin carry
on oh my god I heard that and you go
kids and Ben Gibbard may not hear once
what no thank you
I will let him know that was that couple
you like that the open house I despised
them well they just came back with a new
offer and check that she is uh way over
asking price Ron who cares who they are
that's a massive bid I will be a mogul
how about that cabin 18 years ago for
$2,200 I do not care about the money I
can't even understand what you're saying
right now that Kevin served an important
purpose for me as a quiet refuge from
the nonsense of Modern Life I'd like the
next owners to understand and share that
purpose find me someone like that and
I'll happily sell I'll buy it you can't
afford that house can you afford that
house what would you use it for I'd go
up there and take Andy and champion and
just get away from everyone else and
look at spiders and it's where I'd bury
the bodies of that annoying couple after
I murder them here's my offer I will
give you everything in my purse
$8 a bunch of loose cough drops and
Larry's asthma inhaler thank God I've
been looking for this Larry this is part
of a real estate transaction now you
have no legal claim to it sorry I had no
idea this is the best offer I've heard
yet you tripping right now so don't even
trip your commission
thanks a lot your share mobile
you